bonjour comment ça va j'espère que vous
allez bien regarder ou est ce qu on s
est écrit ici d'où une absence très bon
d'ouverture kane c'est chez samsung
samsung france c'est même écrit ici
s'écrie si c'est écrit partout alors
aujourd'hui on vient présenter des
nouveaux produits qui viennent d'arriver
chez samsung renouvellement de la gamme
pliable galaxie l'attendait
accrochez-vous parce que des noms sont
plongés santo samsung galaxy z flip 3
c'est ça c'est le z flic 4 à 3 4 et puis
est ce que je dis qu'à l'âge au real un
rappel de vacances que font déjà bossé
effet choses entrevues ici avec le z
folle 4 c'est en gros une évolution de
ce qu'on avait déjà mené un lien dans
l'est on avait déjà deux produits
extrêmement bien beauty hyper sexy très
intéressant notamment du côté du cdh
flic 3 qui passait sur wifi 4 cette
année ils ont corrigé légèrement la
copie par rapport à ce qui fonctionne
elle est un petit peu moins bien c'est à
dire des bordures plus fils meilleures
photos bref on va tous regardé ensemble
on va s'expliquer ça et dans quelques
jours bien évidemment il y aura le test
alors si vous n'êtes pas abonné abonnez
vous cliquez sur le bouton rouge activer
la cloche comme ça vous saurez tout le
pays vous le voyez il ya d'autres
produits on a de l'âme ont pas si on a
de la monde par là ils ont même planté
là il ya également des bugs qui sont ici
donc tout ça on en reparlera aussi
ultérieurement bien évidemment ça me
saoule fait un gros lancement samsung
galaxy watch je regarde j'ai les
antisèches watch 5 et 5 propre à la deux
modèles autant par à bientôt et les bugs
et les buzz de projet pas de bêtises
donc ça c'est cool tombe bien évidemment
tous en or par ea met aujourd'hui à
faire un gros focus au niveau des
smartphones qui se plie vous êtes prêt
vous êtes prêt vous êtes prêt on y va
banco
on va déjà commencer par ce qu'on a ici
à savoir le z folz est folle de 4 alors
on connaît le principe de cette folle de
4 pour résumer très rapidement si vous
n'êtes pas coutumier des smartphones de
samsung ils ont deux façons de venir
plier leur smartphone ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle le z folle alors le z folk on le
prend au louvre vous avez donc un écran
qui est juste là et puis à la à
l'intérieur vous avez le plus grand
écran qui vous servira pour venir
consommer du contenu des films du
multitâche et compagnie ça c'est ce
principe là c'est à dire on prend et on
agrandit la zone utile et en face on va
se retrouver avec un smartphone qui
vient diminuer la zone utile c'est celui
là c'est le explique vous avez un
smartphone et vous venez le réduit au
pied dans une poche ou un sac à main
dans ce que vous voulez ça vous regarde
c'est votre problème c'est pratique on
connaît deux écoles un peu différente et
se sont dit ok on va bien amélioré
comment on peut venir améliorer un peu
l'histoire ce qu'ils sont venus faire
déjà c'est réduire toutes les bornes
vous allez retrouver au niveau de votre
smartphone pour faire quoi pour
améliorer la prise en main et surtout
pour venir agrandir d'un point de vue
purement visuel pour pouvoir vraiment
venir augmenter la zone du thil dont
convenu raboter raboter raboter raboter
nous le montre la présentation c'est un
rabotage au laser comme ça on vient
faire des coups francs jeu tous les
côtés ce qui permet d'augmenter la zone
de l'écran au gardon une même taille
d'écran en fait que ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière on a ici un écran
extérieur de 6,2 pouces alors le reste
est un peu différent c'est du 23,1 9e
sont ni augmenter un peu l'histoire avec
un taux de rafraîchissement variable qui
va de 48 heures jusqu'à 120 hertz pour
avoir plus de fluidité 48 heures son
avenir économiser un petit peu la
batterie de son smartphone 120 hertz on
a le maximum pour l'expérience pour
venir notamment scrollé pour des jeux
pour l'instant g et compagnie résolution
hd + 2316 par 904 pixels et puis l'écran
s'éteint dynamique amoled 2 x on a ici
une superbe qualité d'écran et on va
garder la qualité de la dalle votre
écran externe il a été élargi pour quoi
pour lire améliorer l'expérience
utilisateur regardez par exemple la
journée sur un tel peuple à thème sont
repasse sur un thème clair pour vous en
rendiez compte donc on a poussé
légèrement les murs pour venir gagner en
expérience que ce soit plus facile de
venir par exemple taper des sms à deux
doigts si on le souhaite c'est un peu la
même idée que samsung a fait ici à
l'intérieur c'est un écran interne qui
va être plus large et moins haut pour
venir augmenter l'expérience parce qu'un
constat qu'a fait sam soit ici en ayant
mené une étude auprès de leurs
consommateurs c'est que pour faire la
plupart des personnes qui consultaient
du contenu multimédia ne mettez pas leur
smartphone comme ça et regarder comme ça
et c'est un non sens que réel intérêt
devenir le maître comme ça donc ils ont
retravaillé les dimensions tout
smartphone pour le rendre ça plus plus
utile plus pratique et pour qui un vrai
sens propre consommateurs alors
souvenez-vous l'année dernière 28 qui
était intéressant qui est venu nous
mettre c'est la caméra qui se cache ici
en fait sous l'écran on a gardé cette
technologie elle était intéressante ils
ont augmenté la densité de pixels pour
pouvoir améliorer le visionnage alors
probablement mais c'est vrai comme ça en
le regardant on s'en rend pas des masses
démasquant il faudra me laissait bien
évidemment du temps pour elle et des
films des séries pour venir jeu pour
vraiment venir voir si l'expérience
s'est améliorée d'un point de vue
purement immersif avec sept caméras
planquées sous l'écran qui est juste ici
en fait envoyé juste là bon on devine
toujours mais on va s'habituer n'y a pas
de souci là-dessus je m'inquiète pas un
écran de 7,6 pouces c'est une résolution
de 2176 par 1812 pixels d'anémique
amoled 2 x avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va de un air ce
jusqu'à 120 hertz alors ça en vaille à
spy maximum de fluidité en hertz c'est
pourquoi c'est pour venir augmenter la
durée de vie de la batterie de votre
smartphone parce que lorsque vous êtes
en statique vous avez pas besoin de
mettre du 5ème du d'hyères d'ailleurs
les libanais ont été en dire cela pas
besoin d'aller sur du dr si vous restez
uniquement ici sur un ace au minimum
c'est vraiment là où on va dire c'est
pas tout le temps avoir dû hertz mais
comme celle adaptatif et bien ce qui est
intéressant c'est que lorsque vous
n'avez pas besoin vous assure du 1er si
vous économisez réellement la durée de
vie de votre smartphone ou alors autre
truc qui est intéressant également au
niveau de la durée de vie de la batterie
de votre smartphone c'est vraiment ça
qui est intéressant c'est qu'en fait
vous avez ici un processeur de qualcomm
ses instincts dragon 8 + jane un qui est
gravé par tsmc et non pas gravée par
samsung qui téléphonent dragon 8 jane un
faut le savoir petites informations
techniques comme ça ça permettra d'aller
un peu plus loin au niveau de la durée
de vie de votre batterie et ici on a une
batterie de 4400 milliards par heure et
de la recharge rapide 25 quads filaire
15 watts sans fil on a ici 12 igad ram
gddr5 hockey et soit 256 512 ou
carrément intérêt à de stockage pour
avoir la version avec un terrain de
stockage il faut aller sur un samsung
points comme c'est une version exclusive
et autres points aussi qui est exclusif
alors vous le verrez là y'a plein de
coloris au niveau de votre smartphone
ils ont une couleur bordeaux qui est
exclusive à 5,5 points comme donc s'il
vous intéresse venez videmment chaque
fois et bien trouver tous les liens on
va dans la description d'ailleurs ici
c'est l'ivoire je vais avoir qui tentera
site qui a des effets bleuté que j'aime
bien qui est très jolie pas ce que vous
en pensez et puis on a la couleur noire
chez pas le bordeaux ici sous les yeux
si vous voulez le voir une fois de plus
les liens sont en bas dans la
description moi ma petite préférence
celles anthracite je trouve hyper canon
dites-moi lequel vous vous préférez lui
s'en va allez-y à vos claviers côté
résistance on a un corning gorilla glass
victis plus on a de l'aluminium armor
pour venir en rajouter en solidité un
smartphone qui est certifié ipx8 alors
on va pas le jeter dans l'eau mais si
contre un peu d'eau de pluie on va
éviter l'eau chlorée on va éviter l'eau
de la mer ça devrait plutôt bien se
passer c'est assez rassurant mais là où
samsung est venu bosser c'est au niveau
applicatif toute l'expérience logiciels
que vous allez avoir avec one uag alors
ici on peut utiliser avec ou sans stylet
c'est le spn fold edition qu'on avait
déjà l'année dernière c'est exactement
le s pen à 49 euros d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse une faute plus lire dans la
description la vraie nouveauté et si
vous voulez c'est de se dire comment est
ce qu'on pourra venir ramener un peu
plus de services et rend une expérience
beaucoup plus utile et bien ce qu'ils
ont dû faire en fait ils sont dit on va
mettre une petite barre des tâches en
bas alors on va ouvrir quire ça me
saoule note par exemple et là vous voyez
juste en bas vous avez votre petite
barre des tâches alors on appelle ça une
barre des tâches mais en fait si vous
voulez c'est tout ce que vous allez
retrouver ici au niveau de vos
différentes applications niveau des
raccourcis et bien ils vont venir
devenir plus petits pour en faire comme
une barre des tâches l'idée c'est quoi
c'est de pouvoir switcher facilement
entre différentes applications lorsque
vous travaillez de mettre des
combinaison d'applications également ou
alors de venir faire un partage d'écran
très facilement auprès oublie son
division b d'un côté et de l'autre c'est
intéressant votre barre des tâches par
exemple la voulait faire glisser
d'autres applications d'autres côté hop
un petit facebook je prends jules mais
la liste très très facilement lorsque
vous utilisez la parler d'âge disparaît
fait un petit swype là elle revient que
vous pouvez venir vous mettre la france
en la matière je prends une appli hop je
la fait glisser je la mets là donc là je
peux gérer le multitâche très facilement
d'un côté de l'autre je fais comme je
veux c'est une fois de plus toute la
gestion du multitâche qui existaient
qu'on connaissait avant mais comme on a
cette barre des tâches sont là sous les
yeux et je peux dire en permanence parce
qu'elle peut disparaître quand vous
allez dire scrollé ça dépend des
applications mais vous venez changer
très facilement d'une application à
l'autre c'est instantané c'est rapide
c'est pratique donc pour des usages
délire courant plutôt bien fait vous
mettez en bas tout ce dont vous avez
besoin et vomir sa fiche est très
facilement très naturellement et c'est
plutôt pratique autre truc son caleçon
du beausset de par le côté multi tâches
et le glisser-déposer d'un côté l'autre
prend copie au col on glisse ont des
postes c'est une fois de plus des de la
productivité c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya
différencier ces deux smartphones entre
le côté z flip et le z folle le z folle
c'est un smartphone qui va être plus
complet que la lettre analyse plus loin
qui vient prendre la place un peu d'un
galaxy note qui a disparu fin galaxy
note on y apportant un côté folle dble
avec une nouvelle expérience avec de
nouveaux raccourcis avec un grand écran
qui permet d'avoir une barre des tâches
en bas on a également un style est ce
intéressant on le testera très bientôt
donc une fois de plus abonnez-vous s'est
pas déjà le cas comme ça on regardera
cette barre des tâches a réellement un
sens ou si c'est juste un truc un petit
peu on what the fuck on verra ça bientôt
mais c'est vraiment tout cas ce qui
donne adn et l'idée plus intéressante à
ce smartphone là tout en sachant que
cette barre des tâches on l'a ici sur la
quatrième version est bien évidemment
une mise à jour permettra à tous les
possesseurs qui ont une troisième
version de venir la voir donc si vous
avez un samsung galaxy cette folle de
trois ne vous jetez pas sur les épaules
de 4 s'il vous intéresse il ya vraiment
un intérêt pour vous à l'isi ça leur
mise à jour logicielle qui vous
permettra de la voir ça il faut le
savoir un autre point sur lequel samsung
était pas très très bon sur sa version
précédente c'est la partie photo c'était
vraiment reproche qui lui avait été
faite ils ont travaillé ils ont corrigé
ça ils sont mis au niveau de ce qu'on
avait au niveau de la gamme s alors on
refait très rapidement la gamme sc la
gamme photos vidéos sur le très haut de
gamme chez samsung qui est présenté en
début d'année on a eu les 22es 22 +
semaine des ultras et souvent enfin en
tout cas l'année dernière ce qu'on avait
vu c'est que sur le z folle de 3 eh bien
on était toujours un cran en dessous par
rapport à la gamme s alors ici sont dit
on va remonter d'un cran parce qu on
leur reprocher en dit ok samsung c'est
bien tout de proposer un smartphone à
presque deux mille euros voire 2000
euros ça dépend de l'édition mais pour
autant la photo n'était pas à la hauteur
de smartphones beaucoup moins cher va
pas beaucoup moins cher mais quand même
moins cher qu était quand même le haut
de gamme suis un peu l'histoire mais
qu'ils se pliaient pas donc là ils sont
dit ok ok on a compris on va venir m
qu'ils aillent mieux aujourd'hui et si
vous avez un vrai combat ok super
intéressant au niveau de la photo vous
avez la même config que vous avez sur le
f-22 plus à savoir votre grand angle à
50 méga pixels couvre f 1.8 avec une
stabilisation optique vous avez un ultra
grand-angle 12 mégapixels avec autofocus
adua pixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 puis vous
avez un téléobjectif avec un capteur de
10 mégapixels zoom optique x 3
stabilisation optique ouvre à f 2.4 vous
avez à l'intérieur votre petite caméra
ici l'arc et la laque est planqué juste
ici c'est un 4 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
1.8 qui servira vraiment pour venir
converser pour de lapointe mais pour
laisser le fisc on vous recommande c'est
d'utiliser la caméra de saïfi extérieur
qui est au plat également juste ici là
vous la voyez elle cindy mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.2 mais l'expérience la plus
intéressante voulait venir faire des
photos d'un point de vue logiciel pour
prenez votre smartphone vous allez dans
votre application photo c'est mieux que
ça marche pas et vous venez active et
l'écran que vous avez là comme ça vous
voyez vous avez un vrai retour qui est
intéressant alors ya eu plein de choses
plein de mise à jour qui ont été faites
pour apporter plein doute il est
intéressant les tests aura très bientôt
et je le montrerai lors du test se
permettra d'avoir une vision d'ensemble
un peu plus clair sur ce qu'on peut
faire ici en termes de photos et de
vidéos puis on verra surtout si samsung
a vraiment réussi sa copie par rapport à
ce qu'ils nous annoncer ça que ça va
être vraiment intéressant un smartphone
qui a bien évidemment la 5g et qui est
wifi 6e il ya plein de boxe qui sont
arrivés au wifi 6e celui-là est
compatible donc ça aussi c'est chouette
et au niveau des tarifs la version à 256
cas de stockage à la 1799 euros la
version 512 giga de stockage 1919 euros
et puis la version 1 tera exclusif en
samsung points comme elle est à
2159 euros une fois de plus si vous la
couleur bordeaux également sur le site
samsung pain comme voilà ce qu'on
pouvait lire sur ce samsung galaxy z
foyt iv on va regarder le ced philippe
iv ici on a un petit plateau je manquais
différentes couleurs on a du bleu on a
dû violer la vente on a dû crème et on a
du noir à la grosse différence qu'on a
par rapport à l'année dernière c'est que
là toutes les couleurs sont matt pour
une meilleure prise en main du produit
donc on a de la couleur mate c'est sympa
c'est joli moins de traces de doigts et
puis après on les accessoires chez
samsung pour rien mettre des coques les
tenir un peu de tous les côtés ça vous
intéresse une fois de plus vous renvoie
au site samsubin comme le lien est une
fois de plus en bas dans la description
tout en sachant ça c'est plutôt chouette
c'est que vous pouvez pousser la
personnalisation sur l'édition beaspoke
alors le truc en fait vous envoyez des
choix de couleurs avec une partie la
première personnaliser une partie là on
peut venir tout changé vous avez en tout
ça écrit l'a75 combinaisons différentes
exclusivement sur samsung points comme
si ça vous intéresse connaissait
l'histoire le lien juste en bas et par
contre là il faut savoir c'est qu'un
petit délit d'attentes trois semaines
donc vous commandez votre produit comme
il est fait sur mesure pour vous y a pas
de stock il ya un peu d'attentes pour
avoir un produit qui vous ressemble et
unique ça peut aussi être pas mal qu'est
ce qu'il nous raconte ce galaxy z
philippe iv et bien c'est un smartphone
qui va être un poil plus compacts comme
sur cette folle de quatre et sont venus
retravailler au laser pour affiner pour
avoir un produit plus compact qui se
tient bien en main déjà l'oeil de
philippe iii se dit très bien en main la
dans la main je peux dire qu'il devient
invisible c'est faux mais ils ont
optimisé un peu l'histoire on optimise
on gagne un peu en poids on gagne en
taille ça c'est plutôt réussi on garde
la même recette que sur les épaules de 4
corning gorilla glass rictus plus de
l'aluminium armor sur le cadre et une
certification à 200000
d'ouverture/fermeture on peut faire
toute la journée toute la nuit on va
embêter bout d'un moment mais certifié
par veritas ok on a un écran interne de
6,7 pousse ça reste comme l'année
dernière pas de changement ici mais
comme on a rétréci un peu on a
l'impression qu'il est un peu plus cher
c'est une impression pas il l'est
réellement mais l'écran c'est la même
taille on a une dalle ltp aux 2,1 à 120
hertz permettra effectivement
d'améliorer aussi l'autonomie du produit
tout ça couple est au stand dragonne 8
plus de première génération un écran
dynamique amoled 2 x et puis on va ici
jusqu'à 910 au niveau de luminosité
résolution full hd + ça c'est l'écran
intérieur l'écran extérieur il est
bloqué ici tout petit si vous le verrez
bien alors ils se sont dit on va essayer
de l'améliorer un peu l'expérience au
niveau de l'écran extérieur l'idée c'est
de rajouter différentes fonctionnalités
alors comme je le découvre je suis chez
samsung j'ai pas eu tant de bien le
prendre en main je me donne un peu de
temps et je vous dirai ce qu'il en est
lors de mon test ultérieur on peut venir
à priori répondent beaucoup plus
facilement si vous utilisez des buzz de
pro vous pouvez passer un coup de fil
directement ici avec une liste de
quelques favoris que vous aurez
directement sous la main l'idée une fois
de plus c'est d'améliorer l'expérience
utilisateur et donner plus de confort à
son usage avoir bien évidemment et a
testé ici on va voir à 8 gigas de ram
c'est de la lpddr2 cinq exactement comme
sur les épaules de 400 étudiants
déstockage 256 ou 512 pas besoin d'un
terrain ici j'ai pu vous à suivre avec
ce qui est dit si ça suffira largement
un des gros focus que nous montre
samsung ici c'est l'augmentation de la
taille de la batterie pour aller plus
loin au niveau de l'autonomie on passe
d'un 3300 millan période allant de trois
mille sept cent millions terreur c'est
400 millions vous allez avoir en plus
permettront d'aller un peu plus loin de
tenir un peu mieux l'autonomie c'était
un reproche qui avait été fait aux
explique 3 beau smartphone pliant une
nouvelle génération de produits super
intéressant et compact qui d'ailleurs
s'est vendu beaucoup mieux que le z
folle de trois personnes le dire assez
samsung parce que nous avons eu c'est
vrai mais il est évident que si vous
regardez autour de vous dans la rue vous
verrez plus de monde avec un format
comme ça qu avec un format comme ça qui
va destiner à un autre type de clientèle
il faut déjà se dire que ce produit la
raf en tout cas la version 3 pouvait
toucher largement en dessous des 1000
euros à mme était de démocratiser le
pliable et on verra ce qui se passera
avec la version 4 tout en sachant que
samsung à nos catalogues la version 3
via coexister en même temps que cette
version 4 alors ils ont un peu déconné
sur les prix parce qu'il vous dise ok le
prix public vente conseillé ces 999
euros sur la version 3 alors que déjà
vous la trouviez bocoum affaires dans le
commerce bien évidemment après ces deux
revendeurs qui feront leur sauce qui
vous trouvera un travail beaucoup plus
intéressante je donne le tarif à
quelques instants de celui là vous allez
voir c'est aussi pas mal recharge rapide
aussi qui est intéressante ici on va
passer sur du 25 quads filaire 15 watts
sans fil toute l'expérience logiciel
c'est du one way 4.1.1 permettra d'avoir
notamment le flex mode lorsque vous
allez venir faire des photos regarder au
plat je viens plier je passe sur un fait
que ce mode on va pas bien évidemment
lors des phases de test et on verra s'il
ya des nouveautés qui sont arrivés une
partie photo aussi là avec deux capteurs
vous allez retrouver juste ici alors
inventant il 12 mégapixels qui sera 65%
plus lumineux avec une stabilisation
optique sont restés dans ce qu'ils
proposaient en début d'année la night au
graphie des photos de nuit ok vient
améliorer les capteurs et puis un
capteur du très grand-angle de 12
mégapixels tout en sachant que vous avez
également un capteur de 10 mégapixels à
l'intérieur qui est planqué juste ici
autre nouveauté café samsung c'est
purement du logiciel donc si vous avez
de philippe iii vous l'aurez également
ses mises à jour qui va arriver lorsque
vous commenciez à vent à filmer ici
cerner et que vous passiez filmé version
ouverte et bien sa coupe et ça faisait
deux fichiers vidéo là vous allez avoir
une continuité fermé ouvert ouvert fermé
plutôt pratique un smartphone qui est
également certifié ipx8 qu'elle la 5g
ici on n'a pas du wifi si ce uniquement
du wifi 6 alors côté tarifs c'est écrit
là comme ça je lis je vous dis tout la
version 128 go de stockage aller à 1109
euros la version 256 go de stockage à
1169 euros et puis la version 512 à 1289
europe et je lis toujours le z flip 3
qu'il propose sur le store à 999 euros
pour tous créé un peu moins cher il faut
le savoir d'ailleurs je pense que celui
là dans les mois qui viennent mais ce
sera forcément mais déjà comme il est là
plutôt canon et il ya des précommandes
voilà je vous le dis alors je sais
écrire je n'ai pas du tout appris je
vous le dis jusqu'au 25 août
accrochez-vous bien vous avez 150 euros
de bonus reprise de votre ancien
smartphone en plus de sa valeur du tarif
qu'il vaut que vous à 1 150 euros en
plus qui permettra de bien financer
cette petite bête c'est plutôt pas mal
il arrivera le 26 août dans toutes les
bonnes crémeries et puis hein la version
bespoke qu'on peut me dire complètement
customisée personnalisé que les
différentes couleurs elles existent
uniquement en version 256 go de stockage
à 1209 euros elle est un peu plus cher
puisqu'on vient fabriquer que pour vous
et je vous le dis trois semaines de
délai d'attenté ça il faut le savoir et
charlotte samsung galaxy z fold 4 vous
avez également un bonus de reprise de
200 euros en plus de la valeur de votre
smartphone donc bon mois ses smartphones
je trouve intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'on continue à améliorer à aller plus
loin on voit qu'il ya une différence qui
est moins notable entre la version 3 la
version 4 contre la version une et la
version 3 parce qu'après une version 2
en fait ils ont changé le nom pour
devenir réajuster par rapport à la gamme
z fold donc pas ya une jolie évolution
elle est moins notable si vous n'avez
jamais eu de smartphones player de
samsung est que le modèle et flip vous
faisait de l'oeil et bien vous pouvez y
aller les yeux fermés sont très jolis
modèles super canon comme ça j'aime
aussi beaucoup le z fold c'est différent
c'est vraiment deux façons de concevoir
le client deux usages différents deux
besoins différents je pense que si c'est
plus un usage destiné aux professionnels
aux gens qui ont vraiment de la
productivité je voulais aller toujours
plus loin qu'ils veulent un stylet voilà
je sais pas lequel vous botte le plus
petit moi ce que vous en pensez qu est
ce qui vous plaît qu'est ce qui vous
plaît pas qu'est ce que vous aimez
qu'est ce que vous aimez pas est ce que
vous êtes satisfait déçu quelles étaient
vos attentes marqué tout ça bien
évidemment juste en bas en commentaire
n'oubliez pas on parle de smartphones
mais on regardera également les buzz
d'ici quelques temps on prendra le temps
de mettre aux oreilles et puis de voir
si la qualité est au rendez-vous et puis
même chose du côté des montres on les
mettra pas aux oreilles c'est un petit
peu compliqué vu que sont démontrés pas
des écoutes a certainement fait des
grandes bouteilles ce serait moche et
ont recelé mettra au poignet on ira se
balader avec et puis on verra si le
rendu est là si le retour elle a aussi
bien du côté de la watch saint cloud
cinq pros ça c'est cool mark et moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
on se trouve très vite pour continuer
bien évidemment à parler de quoi ça me
saoule de teck l'actu et la laque tués
de plus en plus présente là on est au
mois d'août on va bientôt attaquer le
mois de septembre ils sont énervés tous
les sourds innervé salut nombre
d'e-mails qu'on reçoit pour dire tiens
il va seria ça c'est la folie folie
c'est cool allez vous embrasse pour le
soin de vous et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]